Quick update from our poll on the David Pakman
show YouTube channel, as many of you no doubt
know, uh, Andrew Yang dropped out of the presidential
campaign after an abysmal 2.8% of the vote
on Tuesday in New Hampshire.
Uh, it was the right thing to do.
And yesterday we asked on our YouTube channel,
who should drop out next?
And overwhelmingly our audience believes that
it is outgoing.
Hawaii Congresswoman tool C Gabbert who should
drop out next to the poll was after seeing
the results of Iowa and New Hampshire, which
Democrats should drop out of the race.
Next 25,000 of you voted and 42% a significant
plurality believed that it is tool.
See who should drop out next 28% say Joe Biden
should drop 14% say Elizabeth Warren, 13%
say Tom Stier.
Now I imagine that there is some satire here.
Elizabeth Warren already has delegates and
Stire has none.
It's hard to argue.
Warren should drop out before a Tom Stier
does, although he may actually end up with
more delegates by the time we get to super
Tuesday because if Elizabeth Warren gets no
delegates in Nevada and Stire does well in
South Carolina, he's polling well there.
It's actually conceivable that going into
super Tuesday, Tom Stier could have roughly
the same number of delegates or maybe slightly
more than does Elizabeth Warren.
Um, it is time for Tulsi to go, but I actually
don't really care that much if she stays in.
I mean at this point, if somebody wants to
donate to her, it seems like burning money,
go ahead and do it.
She's not really getting coverage anymore.
She's not at the debates.
It's like, you know, stay in.
I, I don't really care one way or the other.
Uh, but mathematically I don't see a path
for tools C to get even a single delegate
STI or at least can say I'm going to get delegates
in South Carolina.
Probably.
Um, I don't see a path to a single delegate
for toolsy Gabbert.
So my question to you is, if you have a mathematical
case for tool seat not being the next to drop,
I want to hear from you.
I don't want to hear, well, tool C has a case
because she's the only candidate against the
forever Wars.
That's not a mathematical argument.
I want to hear something that challenges the
idea that tool C has zero delegates and has
no path to a single delegate.
Why should she stay in on that basis?
Uh, get in touch and let me know